my name is donnie i'm a customer data
architect at census so what i do is i i
help uh prospects and uh and customers
like use our product to to work on
operational analytics um and kind of the
title of the talk it's kind of modern
data snacks kind of like we'll use food
we have a bunch of m ms at the end of
the talk or during if you want to go
grab them um and like the point of of
this is to talk about kind of using
operational analytics walk through a
couple use cases and how data
can have a seat at the table
within a business
to move kind of uh to move and just
increase the leverage by building trust
with the organization
so
kind of quick agenda
uh like number one's like kind of that
recipe which is like the hub and spoke
model of the modern data stack basically
using the data warehouse as the nervous
system of an organization
um kind of like we'll talk through like
a couple diagrams of like what that can
look like
um
number two is kind of like building the
buffet um kind of how uh
operational teams can self-serve data
into their tools
um and kind of we're going to talk about
kind of use cases the sales use case as
well as a marketing use case
and then we'll kind of walk through two
live demos we'll kind of have like a
half time if anyone wants to go
grab a drink of water or
need to walk out for a sec and then
we'll jump back in and walk through the
marketing use case
um and then we'll talk through kind of
how
how operational analytics can be used
for your career in data and for uh
increasing
like data visibility within the
organization um
talk a little bit about the landscape
what else is already out there in terms
of
in terms of solutions or current ways
that people are solving the problem and
then
kind of throughout like
feel free to interrupt me with questions
if you have any uh but we'll have a
section for at the end as well
let's go ahead and get started um so
what is operational analytics um opera
like at a high level operational
analytics is
bringing that analytics that is already
living in your data warehouse or in your
data hub and bringing that into business
tools that ops user users are using and
living in on a day-to-day basis
so
commonly that's salesforce and like the
crm use case uh zendesk or intercom and
like support uh and then marketing we're
gonna walk through a linkedin use case
uh but kind of google ads facebook ads
uh being able to support all the
different apps that a business uses
connectivity is a super important part
and
census is
syncs that data from your from your
single source of truth and in in from
your bi tools
into your operational tools so if you'll
see kind of like this overall
architecture you have like five tran as
like that elt
spoking in to the hub you have segment
also handling kind of that event and
just spoking
in dbt is just like a layer
within your hub
and then censuses that spoke out into
your business tools
um and then kind of like
thinking about kind of a lot of the the
different use cases
and a lot of like the there's a lot of
data science and machine learning that's
that's here um so like is like does this
still count is this still operational
analytics um kind of if we have like
some complicated data pipelines we might
use like a kafka stream or snowplow for
event ingest um and the answer is like
yes um
kind of we
we have an interoperable api that you
can trigger within whatever your data
engineering ecosystem is uh we've like
an operator for airflow a task for
prefect um and like we can work with
dagster as well um and kind of the key
the key like
architecture that's the same in this
case uh is kind of having that
centralized hub
and kind of for any analytics work or
any
data science machine learning that
you're doing as long as that's coming
into the hub
like that fits very well with uh with
our vision um as an architecture and you
can send that into your different
business and ops tools
and kind of like a great question is
like why why is this important why would
people want to do this
and the answer is just like the current
process
generally either looks like these two
things or it doesn't exist so
number one is like there's a spaghetti
stack
of many different point-to-point
integrations
um
another side like there's just a bunch
of manual csv uploads that happen in the
tools um and like if you've ever come
across like a
like a download upload process with like
data export one data for two data export
three like
it's probably a good signal that uh an
operational analytics tool like census
might be might be good for you
um
and kind of with that spaghetti stack of
point-to-point integrations like you
have to manage that scale is very fast
so if you want to add a new tool you
might need to add on like eight
different integrations
um and kind of make sure that all the
wiring is hooked up correctly and you
might lose some of that visibility and
observability into those different tools
so
that's what that's what census can can
give
is kind of that observability
as well as just building that out as a
robust system
um
that that can that can last the the test
of time
so
that's kind of like that first section
any questions in terms of operational
analytics and kind of
why it's needed
cool
you can kind of talk a little bit more
about like that
that self-serve side and kind of
what like why
what do business teams want to do with
this analytics information and why why
does data care about that too
so in terms of use cases some common
ones that we see
is just being able to get like a this
360 degree customer record
um being able to have
a view
into like who your customers are what
they're doing
within the product that's often not
living in like the sas tools that uh a
sales person or a sales ops person is
actually using
um you don't you don't have that same
context when a salesperson is hopping on
the phone
um with the customer like they might
have to
answer questions that we should already
know
um another side is just consistent
reporting
and the amount of time that like a
report from a different tool doesn't
match up with the bi tool or a report
doesn't match up between multiple
different tools kind of that that hub
and spoke approach can fix that
by making sure you have the same
information
that's mirrored in in all of your
different systems
and the third use case is like a
specific one which would be like lead
scoring so kind of more thinking about
product led growth um and how can you
actually
leverage different information about
product usage
to
identify sales leads that then you could
go ahead and reach out to
so any questions on kind of like these
sales use cases
if not i'm going to kind of walk walk
through a demo of the product
sorry i'm gonna find my mouse
cool um we're gonna go ahead and jump
into models this is the census ui um
kind of at a high level we have kind of
a couple different components here
um
this is the connections tab
so the connections tab you'll connect
your data source um and then
kind of in terms of that connectivity
pillar that we talked about
um you want to go ahead and like
a pillar is that we want to be able to
support all the different business apps
that you'd want to use
so we can kind of scroll down and take a
look at some of these
but the one that we want the two that we
want to talk about today are salesforce
and linkedin ads
something that's that's worth
flagging here too is that there are we
have the ability to
um to customize uh like to to have we
have a custom api so if you want to
build out an integration um that you
that is not currently supported natively
um you can still gain a lot of that
observability and that alerting from
census uh with the with the flexibility
of building out your own custom api uh
and we have some starter code to do that
as well
if the system that you need data in
is not currently natively supported same
thing with web hub so we have like that
custom api integration
right here and then as well as well as
that web hook
any any questions um about kind of like
the the different apps
or the connectivity pillar
cool
i'm just gonna go ahead and jump into
models um
you can see that like models are you can
think of as like queries basically
tables that you want to link up from the
source
uh that we want to go ahead and send
into different destination systems so in
this case like um we can connect to a
dbt project
um kind of you get that same
observability that you might get um that
you can get at like in terms of where
that's actually being sent into
um really how that works is it's just
running the compiled query uh to pull
that from dbt um additionally like we
have the ability to connect looker looks
kind of using lookers api
to pull out that actual compiled query
um that then we can go ahead and use as
a source as well um so especially this
is useful if you have any
business logic that's built in bookml
that you like want to be able to send
somewhere
you go ahead and hook that up through
census as well
kind of for the use case that i want to
talk to you today is
um just like using this contact table so
um
it's count this this kind of
big company that i call jaffa gaggle um
and it was like a dbt project that i
worked on uh but basically you can think
about it like a
um
kind of
like a b2b
place um where we have like
users and customers that uh place orders
uh and then we want to go ahead and send
that data into salesforce
so you'll see like we just have a couple
users we have
user id
we have like their corporate email as
well as like username a couple of just
data points that you might that might be
typical of what might come from your
product database that's in your
in your data warehouse
that salesforce otherwise would have no
record of
so in that case i want to go ahead and
set up a sync
so i'm going to go ahead and add a sync
i'm going to go ahead and connect this
to the salesforce
this is the sync this is really the the
heart the meat of what census does
um so the way like we we pull from the
source we can connect to a model
uh we can also connect to like just a
like a warehouse table review
but in this case i want to
go ahead and connect to that
context
and then you want to select the object
that you want to sync to
so when we think about kind of the
different connectors that we build the
different integrations that we have
we really think about kind of the depth
of the use case
um and being able to support the
different customers that are using the
different integrations that we have
so for salesforce we support
kind of every every single every object
in terms of custom objects and standard
objects as well as the ability to like
sync to multi-destination objects so
leader account
or leader contact depending on the
different flow that you might have on
the salesforce side
um kind of if
kind of our documentation
kind of will show what objects we
support for the different integrations
that we have as well as like which
behavior that we have um
so i want to sync to the contact object
sorry
cool
so i want to sync to in this case just
to the contact object
and then we have to define kind of how
we want to
to this the sync to behave so in this
case like do i want to if if this
contact already exists i want to update
it if it doesn't i want to create it
um so i'm going to do it like that
basically we have to define kind of how
we want
the data from your table or from your
data warehouse to be joined
to that object in the destination and
for this case i'm just going to use an
external id but oftentimes you see that
being a user email
or like an external id that would come
from
your
your product database
and then
first off any questions here in terms of
like the sink behavior
great yeah that would be like a deployed
microservice like within like a customer
hub or like we can kind of help you
configure it as well if you'd like but
basically we have a certain protocol
um
certain
so that kind of point b
that then would handle that
uh so you'd send data to it from
sentence and then sentences would also
leak data back
to be able to use the same engine that i
can kind of
oh
great question yes so um short answer is
yes and then
like we have an invalidation check so if
this this primary column if that's
duplicated or if that's not we won't
send it
but they're in uh those were valid notes
in that case because that meter hadn't
placed
so like if they didn't have any orders
for them
so if that's fine
but we need to send that thing
but in terms of the need identifier
problems like that
um and then if the destination api
rejects
a record because of the data value
you'll
will not send that question
um but yeah
so that's that that's that mapping step
in terms of mapping column
um then like we have the ability to
choose
any of the different fields that we want
to go ahead and sync over
including like lookup fields so if you
wanted to
look up kind of from a contact to the
account
that that should be tied to on the
salesforce side
which is like a super common use case
for a lot of different services
that's something that we would that we
want to be able to support
um but in this case like i already have
the field set like the names match for
what i want to send over so i just want
to go ahead and like choose these
you'll see that like
to smear kind of to talk about a little
bit more about your point uh in terms of
like that data validation check you can
see that like we have these little icons
here in terms of like making sure that
we're sending the correct data type from
your source to the correct data type in
your destination
so that's another another layer that we
have here
we want to and something that we also
enable here is to be the ability to run
a test so running a test would send
would run a sync but would only send one
record over to the destination
so yeah so that would be like if you
wanted to if like
great like i've i've
for certain services that might not have
a sandbox or development environment
um you might not want to kick off a full
sync
but you'd want to just send over one
record and see how that actually looks
in the destination
um
and then you can just make sure that
that looks good and then cool spot check
and go ahead
yes
exactly
any question on the field mapping or any
of the behaviors for the sinks
kind of one thing that i'm going to flag
here to
that we're not going to talk about um
specifically today
um but this is like the the entity sink
kind of sinking to a noun
like a noun as in a contact in
salesforce there's another concept which
is like events so like facebook
conversion events or
a mix panel event
that we also have the ability to sync to
so those would be like we would append
that
to the destination that we also see a
use case for in terms of
whether it's uh like events that you
would capture through snowplow and you
have funneling in your data warehouse or
events that you would get from a
transactional database
and then translate towards a synthetic
event so if you have like an order
creation date that you would have in
your transactional database but you
don't have like your event hooked up
you can just call that event like order
created and then send that over as an
event to the different systems that you
want to
that's a use case that i've been seeing
a lot more lately as well
cool i'm just going to go ahead and kick
off the sync
kind of uh
this is like we're this is going to
populate this this dashboard of just
like contacts here um with kind of like
the relevant information
um and
like this is
super can be super relevant within
organizations
especially when the ops users uh are
like
finding that things aren't matching up
within their systems
to like the
um
to like up like the analytics or the
dashboards that like they might be
pulling from um so being able to have
kind of
like
the sync creation be fairly streamlined
and fairly straightforward um for these
ops users to be able to self-serve
information um
but like with kind of the quality check
of
it being a dbt model or it being like a
data team approved model um
that's kind of where where we see like
that gourmet buffet idea of the data
team adding those quality checks uh
before that actually can go down into
the downstream system
um
we'll talk a little bit more about that
later
but uh just want to talk a little bit
about kind of some of these
configuration here
um so we have the ability to just set
this up on a schedule
um go ahead and set this up
on weekly daily
hourly up to every 15 minutes uh
continuous um continuous is like kind of
micro batches we would scan the
warehouse
every one to two minutes and any changes
that are detected will be go ahead we'll
go ahead and send that over
and yeah that's how that works and the
way that we're able to do that um is we
will have a state tracking schema within
our within our customers warehouse um
and
that that way
kind of
we sort the snapshots of the maps
columns of the data
so we can do the diffing logic within a
warehouse
and like you don't store any of your
data at rest
yeah totally so we we do it's the data
warehouse we'll do like a selected set
to pick up the change rows on the data
warehouse side
and then we'll just go ahead and send
those over
so we don't need a column or a timestamp
for a laptop did that
we just need the values that will
actually
compare
and kind of data warehouses like
can handle these
for very high volumes of data very fast
that answer your question yeah
um
we also have the ability to like kick
off a sync via dbt cloud
um or
like kind of that interoperability piece
that i was talking about earlier you can
go ahead and use kind of an api trigger
just sending a post to this endpoint
we'll go ahead and kick off a sync
um and you can have that live within
whatever ecosystem or orchestration
layer that you have
um looks like this sync probably has
gone ahead and finished but before that
get like an activity log on the sync in
terms of like great i just created this
um and then you have the ability to
configure alerts so if a sync fails um
all the way up to uh different
thresholds for when
for how successful a sync is um to
actually kick off an alert that you
would get through slack
through email
or slack or page or duty or wherever
you'd like to get notified if something
fails
um
great so looks like this thing is
finished up
kind of uh this is that invalidation
check
so if any if any records are uh
like have duplicates in in that mapping
column that they will like be flagged
and not sent over um and then kind of
any rejected records like this one
um like this one has a comma in the in
the email address
um
and so this gets rejected by salesforce
and we're able to reject that at the
record level as opposed to like the
batch level so the rest of the batch
succeeded
uh but this went ahead this this failed
and this is for uh
debugging purposes
it would have to be corrected in the
data warehouse today um something that
we're
excited about
doing as well is kind of with that right
access that we have to that schema for
that state tracking um we're going we're
like in the in the process of enabling
like writing back these rejected records
into your warehouse
so you can have the record there and
then if you wanted to surface that and
be like okay cool like this is the
id of the record in that table that i
would need to adjust
that you can kind of like add that to a
workflow as well
um but yeah does that answer your
question
any more questions on the sync history
piece
cool uh let's go ahead
refresh this
great so we have uh so like these are
like those nulls right like the
people that didn't haven't actually
placed orders like those would come in
here as just dashes
um and and the reason why this is
um why this is so important for
like a salesperson to get their data
within a tool like this
um is so that they can kind of slice and
dice it and do whatever they want to do
with their sales workflow um within a
tool that they can actually take action
on so like if i wanted to just go ahead
and like
just grouped by
like that's grouping by the most recent
event so it's not that helpful
um but yeah like this is like the
specific days that these contacts were
actually active or these users
um and then like i can click in to hear
this record
see like some of that information and
then i guess for a sales person i can go
ahead and actually take action if i want
to log events or
add follow-up tasks i can do that
as well as kind of configure workflows
in these tools um that
sales ops people
are often thinking about um and
that actually like they basically live
in these tools
um
from from that perspective uh and kind
of the data team and the ops team like
this can bridge this gap um such that
like
if a new field is needed to be added
here um you go ahead into configuration
and then you can just go ahead and
quickly add a field uh versus needing to
edit an existing pipeline
um just to go ahead and add that on so
it's
fairly straightforward in terms of a
sales person that might want to jump in
and add
ads add data that would be coming
cool um
any
any questions about the kind of the
sales use case
that would that we can kind of answer
now um
that was kind of like the sales piece to
the demo
um
so
kind of like
i just wanted to call like a quick half
time if anyone wants to grab water or
something feel free you want to grab m
ms
happy to answer any questions
we're going to be talking a little bit
uh
more and more in depth about like the
sales use case
uh next week uh i'll i'll be deleting
that um as a webinar which will be super
fun um and then we also have uh the
ability to kind of sync yourself to swag
uh if you want you just go in
and then like edit
and you will use kind of that custom api
for uh
for us to to send you a sql t-shirt
table with the conference
our inverse
um
me
uh
yes
all right
okay
thank you
oh yeah
so
cool um
all right we're going to go ahead and
kind of get get started with the
marketing use case um
thanks thanks for the the half time it
was nice to chat and
hang out um
kind of like
want to talk about kind of like what we
talked about like what sales does with
operational analytics now i want to talk
to focus a little bit more on like what
marketing does with operational
analytics
um and a big piece is around kind of
segmenting in audiences
on kind of like customer lists so if you
think about like use cases you might
want to exclude your current customers
from like spending to get them to click
on ads or show them ads
um you might want to to like you
leverage look like audiences to uh like
allow
like
facebook or google or snapchat to try to
find
users that look like those users
um that you already have um you might
wanna like you might have like an
a renewal coming up for a customer and
you want to like
have like hyper target hyper targeted
marketing campaigns at like renewals or
potential upsells for your existing
customers
um or like you might want to use
those conversion events that we were
talking about like
actually placing an order or completing
your onboarding flow
kind of deeper in the funnel moments
that you can go ahead and kind of set up
an offline conversion event
um we're going to go
in like a couple weeks we have like a
little bit more in-depth
another webinar about like kind of
operational analytics for marketing um
but i'm excited to kind of walk you
through using that same customer list
and then syncing that into
linkedin
for the potential for for showing ads
so let me see what my mouse is good
cool um so i'm going to go ahead and go
back to that
japanese contacts um so you'll notice we
have this status here
um and what this status means is like
it's basically the data team being able
to stamp
approval um of a model or of like a sql
query
or a model that might come from dbt
um and that exposes the ability to
create a segment um and what a segment
is uh
is basically
just the ability to kind of have use a
no code builder um on top
of like an already existing
data model um that's already living in
your data warehouse so uh a key a a time
we see we see this often with uh like
marketing users that want the ability to
just create audiences and audience lists
um that they might not know sql
but if they have like
the the list of customers with all of
the different metrics that you might
want to have
they could go work off of that to create
their different audiences and sync those
into different business tools um
so like i have like number of events
greater than 25 we can support a number
of different
data types uh and like we have like the
less than 120 days ago
um like you want a boolean like that
that also can handle uh you can
functionally think about this like a
where clause at the end of a sql query
um
but
any questions here on kind of segments
yeah
you have formatted um
for example um they don't have a date
so if you have like a
year your year month month day
like
iterable will not accept that as a valid
big time
so
like
it will convert that to the tax which
will give you a warning or before we
send that out
kind of all of the data types that we
use that are different like for redshift
it's like a superflame for like their
date times and timestamps and all the
different types depending on the
different sources
um so that's part of like when we add
that on
uh
great question
cool
um i'm just gonna go ahead and set up a
sync
so you can see that like
uh another important part of this
in terms of like these segments and in
terms of
like operational analytics being the
same spoke so you can reuse that
definition and across a number of
different channels um so i already have
this being synced into google ads i'm
going to configure it for linkedin ads
so i have
this just as my new data source
i'm going to go ahead and select
linkedin
um i'm going to go ahead and select this
is a user list because these are my
users
um
and then we need to choose like that
identifier
again um in this case like i have that
email
so i'm going to go ahead and use that
um for many of the marketing use cases
they like only accept sjsh
hash
data
so you can either send give census your
unhashed data in census will hash it for
you in flight or you can also have it
prehashed
and then we just won't touch it we'll
send it as is
um and then you have like different
like identifiers like we support
different identifiers for every
different object
but in this case i just want just the
email
it's like that email
and then um we have the ability here to
be able to add that to an existing
existing user list that comes from
linkedin
or the ability to create one
so like
i can just go ahead and create like
engaged
users
um
do like
spreadsheet
eminem
and that will go ahead and create that
as
as an audience
in linkedin um and i'll just go ahead
and pull that up
so this looks like this
like
basically what you can do in linkedin is
you can have this be a user list and
then on top of that you can configure
your different audience logic that you'd
want for the different ad campaigns
but let's go jump back here great
so i have that
i want to just go ahead and add like
first name last name um the way that
these market these advertising tools
work is that um you'll pass it like a
unique identifier and then as much
personal information as you have um and
then these tools will match based on
like their own internal data sets to be
able to identify like to write to like
handle the resolution between what you
know about a customer and what these
tools know
so that they can target those people
so that's why you hear about like match
rates and whatnot in these advertising
use cases
um you can go ahead and send the test
but i'm just going to go ahead and kick
off the sink
um for this this segment here
um
and i'll go ahead and create it
one thing um that one thing that's that
that we often see is like when we have
like a sliding window like this filter
that i have um from this segment
is that we'll have the you can configure
a mirror sync
and what a mirror sync does is like if a
if the user no longer meets
the criteria for that for that segment
uh a sync will go ahead and delete that
from that audience in the destination
um so that like if you have like a
four month window and someone had
ordered like
three months and 29 days ago
and like they're in the list and then
like it syncs again in like four days
like that user would then be deleted
from that list because it no longer
meets that criteria
um really common case that we see with a
lot of these advertising destinations
cool um
we have like yeah just kind of the
alerting i mean any questions in terms
of
kind of like this this advertising use
case this is
one that like
remember that if we go back to that
that slide this is often one um
that this is the case for either a
marketing ops person or the marketing
team themselves a lot of csv downloads
and a lot of csv uploads
that census can just help automate
um and kind of add that that quality
control
and the
like you can
it's a very
straightforward for data to get an easy
win with the marketing team um to like
have this run on a schedule have this be
automated use your first part data that
you already
you send the have to linkedin
like is that like
so it knows who that user is
be targeted towards
my understanding is that you can only
show ads to specific audiences like if
you wanted to do like account based
marketing
my understanding is that you can do that
based on like certain accounts that you
might want
to
advertise to or like
or like that audience
plus
like look likes of that audience um
but like that's that's my best
understanding i don't know if they
should you know
linkedin facebook
um
essentially
but the way that i would do it
is this messy csv to the right
so something more than isolate bottles
of hot sauce
i love csv data export
processes
um
and uh well
first off i want to just go ahead and uh
partner there's there's another piece
here
um which is that like
these audiences take time to build so
like that match process like you can
like this on this this customer list
that's created
but linkedin has its own matching
algorithm that it will it has to run
to to go ahead and do that so you'll see
like i uploaded the volume
um now they're ready um and then like
it'll give you a rough estimate of how
many people fit that audience
um in facebook it'll give you a match in
google it'll give you a match rate
um i think facebook will also give you a
match rate as well um so in terms of who
they're able to identify
um
great and then like
kind of like to touch on that point as
well like
these these audiences these entities
like in terms of this logic you want to
be able to have that synced into all of
your different tools
um
so not only just linkedin but
maybe google or facebook or snapchat tic
tac or bing like
um
they
and this is specifically
important because you will always have
access to your user data like with like
whatever the user data that you put in
um like that you might need to sign up
to an account you might need an email
you might get some of that personal
information anyway um and kind of like
with
like kind of some of the cookie tracking
and that browser tracking
um like you have the like
you always still have that data in your
warehouse
um that like you're able to like
let make that customer data work for you
in this way
any questions
here in terms of this this marketing use
case
um
if not kind of want to i want to share
let's see if this works the audio here
fingers crossed
when my co-workers always said that i'm
a data angel because i previously
thought i was you know elf on the shelf
like the little
elf and santa's factory delivering the
data but i'm actually like
he rebranded it he's like you know
you're a data angel i'm like oh and i
thought of it that way it's such a good
reminder that so many people in a
company it's like you're bringing them
something don't they don't have so it's
like yeah it feels like
magic from the heavens oh
and then eventually they'll get used to
it and then they'll just complain when
the data is broken but exactly at first
it really does feel like this gift yeah
um so that this was from uh a recent
podcast uh the sequel show that that
sentence puts on with with our ceo boris
um this is this is jessica cherny she's
the like she does data analytics at
ironclad which is a customer of census
um she also leads a a great community a
slack community
uh of like women in data called data
angels uh some shout out to her um
but uh i i do want to talk about like
that in terms of like being
like
the data elf on the shelf and kind of
this concept of like being able to bring
like this data to ops users and how
like how important and like
how much of a of a gap there is that can
be bridged by this concept of
operational analytics um and like
[Music]
come on there it is like
um like operational analytics is
this bridge that like that lines up
those two backgrounds between like the
data and the actual data practice like
the users of the data
within an organization financial
organization customer success logistics
all of these different components that
work within a business um they need to
consume data and there are processes
that can be optimized by using the right
kind of analytics
um
additionally like
that that that request and like that
complaining when the data is broken um
that data the fact that data team has to
respond a lot to operational requests if
the ops users are able to self-serve
that data um from a trusted source like
if like all of those
those salesforce dashboards all of that
marketing data has the sample of
approval for what is
the definition of a customer
um and what is like the definition of
product usage like
there are less quality issues that might
happen less data mismatching
um and like you can kind of you can
approach self-serve
in a way that will give the data at the
fingertips and the tools that ops people
um
and additionally like with that
observability functionality with like
the data typing not sending over
duplicates with being able to alert when
things fail
um
and being able to like be resilient with
dealing with the post apis for these
systems that are
super unreliable um it's building agile
like adaptable resilient systems for the
long term
um that like you you don't need to build
out an integration for each different
tool you can let census handle the
observability the alerting
and kind of the headache of integrating
with your different systems
um
that will enable you
uh as a data person to focus more on
uh to move from just kind of measuring
like simple kpis like what is our
customer acquisition cost
you know what's our channel base and our
what are our sales numbers um to be able
to like move them to use
operational analytics to build trust
within an organization
to
be like at the table um talking about
how do we lower our customer acquisition
costs how should we think about our data
definitions
how would we want to increase our
revenue
and our revenue retention rate what are
some strategies
that actually put this into practice and
how can we operationalize
the insights that we have
so often data is like not left
is not brought to that discussion when
there's a ton of truth and information
that david can add within the
organization in this context
operational analytics is a way to build
that trust with those stakeholders
any questions about this
um
great so uh
why is operational analytics different
um and i i'd say that there are three
main
uh like three main
components to what
like in terms of existing solutions that
are out there
like one is kind of a custom integration
that might be like sometimes i hear it
described as like python code wrapped in
duct tape uh in terms of just
integrating different systems you might
have that um like maybe using a like
different different frameworks uh or
sdks of the services
um
but uh there's a lot of maintenance cost
to open source system or open source or
home build systems um you need to build
it you need to maintain it when
something breaks you gotta like hop in
and like solve
why
um
you also like need to build out alerting
or resiliency um at least for many of
the systems that
i built
um i did not build out proper alerting
systems or resiliency um so i spent a
lot of a lot of time when something
failed
like reworking what why it failed
playing a lot of time spending data like
spent a lot of time
playing data detective in that way
and then like you just need to deploy a
new integration you need to build a new
integration for every new tool you want
to add
another one is like customer data
platforms um so why why is that
different like
what what is what are like
pieces here is like that once you turn
on a stream that comes from a cdp like
it's on um like you turn on and like the
hose starts going um and these are event
based systems so like one like they
happen at like a one
uh one of one event like a click page
view um what are they really good at
they're really good at like
event capture
and identity stitching
um but they're not they they weren't
designed to handle uh or give
observability into uploads into tools
imports into different different systems
um and like oftentimes like
costs will scale as data volumes scale
so as your customer
base is growing
like
the cost for cdp often grows
proportional to the growth rate of your
customers um almost penalizing you for
for like being successful
um
and then kind of like ipas or kind of
point-to-point similar like event-based
uh general model um you don't have as
much observability into when they fail
they can they tend to fail silently um
and you don't have like that kind of
holistic observability features
um or kind of like reliability when
things fail
and kind of
how is how is oa different like
operational analytics pulls like the
most recent data from the definitions of
the hub you don't have to like fix
bespoke integrations at each different
point to point
new integrations can be configured and
synced in minutes
we just walked through two use cases
salesforce and linkedin we did that
probably all in 10 minutes tops
so you could you see like as long as you
have the data
living in your data warehouse
you can go ahead and get that set up
right away
um
another another piece is that costs are
predictable they don't penalize your
business for growing um the sentences
cost model is based on destination
fields so what are the the columns in a
table that you are syncing over to the
different destination objects it doesn't
depend at all on data volumes it doesn't
depend
uh there are no hidden fees regarding
that
um and then like that observability
alerting
scalability that's all built in uh
within the architecture such that like
you don't have to worry about if things
fail like
census can just take care of that for
you
um
great like thanks for joining um
a quick shout out to uh
our
operational analytics slack community
that we have um that parker
uh is is a member of and and is leading
um and like feel free to sign up for a
free trial um and feel free to ask me
any questions it's great chatting with
you today
i really appreciate it